I think creative blocks come from
people's life journeys if you don't know
who you are or what you're about or what
you believe in it's really pretty
impossible to be creative so I think a
lot of times when people have
quote-unquote creative blocks and and I
know my share of friends do as well if
they're at just some stuck point they're
not sure what to do with their lives or
their or their writing or their
photography or their filmmaking or or
whatever it is that they're doing I
think the best advice is to you have to
change your life up completely to go on
a trip to go spend a year being of
service be willing to take some major
drastic action to get you out of your
comfort zone and go inside not outside I
think our society is all about focusing
on the external x' oh these people like
me I'm successful because of these
people they view me as being good and we
need to take that vision and instead of
expanding it outwards we need to look
inside ourselves
I think meditation helps greatly with
creativity it doesn't if it's a pure
expression of yourself no matter what it
is or what medium it's gonna shine it's
gonna resonate you could look inside of
yourself and you can have a canvas and
you could paint a dot in it but if
that's where your creative purpose is
taking you then it needs to be that dot
again we're so focused on the externals
about like well he did this and he
already did this and tons of people are
already doing that I need to do
something new and you're just looking
outwards all the time and you're not
taking that time and that's what a trap
of technology is to just always have our
vision somewhere else somewhere else in
the future looking outside of ourselves
and I think taking the time in the
morning to connect with your breath
that's where the the purest impulse
comes from
creativity is absolutely for everyone I
firmly believe this I think if you're
the driest accountant with the plastic
pocket pen protector it's it's in how
you interact with the world there's
artistry in everything that we do and
there's expression in everything that we
do and you see that in the game of chess
you know as you I used to play a lot of
chess and competitive chess and study
chess and as you get to see the
grandmasters and learn their styles when
you start copying their games like the
way they express themselves through you
know the way Kasparov or Bobby Fischer
expresses themselves through a game of
chess --is it's astonishing you can show
a chess master one of their games and
they'll say oh yeah that's done by that
player so it doesn't matter it's it's um
it's it's again about that that yearning
to transcend there's a surrender to a
power greater than oneself as every
artist or scientist or thinker talks
about a certain point when it's no
longer like their brain it's like the
ideas are like streaming through them
and that can happen with anyone if
you're a if you're a janitor you can do
it through your work or on the side or
how you are with people but this is the
mission of SoulPancake is to show that
everyone is an artist everyone is
creative in their own way and that that
creativity is a great thing it's a human
thing and it needs to be nurtured and it
can help us go down life's path and help
us to become deeper richer more
satisfied human beings